the findings of our comprehensive
thorough and independent investigation
has led us to believe that we have
probable cause to file criminal charges
our time to prepare that trust to come
together collectively as a community to
start to break down the barrier to
progress in our communities is now the
beaches we just watch this liquor store
being looted and there's a bunch of
folks running in and out of there yeah I
do it nothing what's wrong with that
deploy the police are all the way down
there new city council member is that
right is it right for people to loot no
I'm you know I think you've missed
everything I've taught there